in the country Retreats where Winston
Churchill spent so much of the war a
welcome for a man now so often compared
to him president zielinski was flown by
military helicopter to Checkers for a
surprise visit ending a Whistle Stop
tour of Europe greeted and honored by
the Prime Minister Winston Churchill
made many of his famous speeches in
World War II from this run and in the
same way today your leadership your
country's bravery and fortitude are an
inspiration to us all
there was plenty of symbolism and a
place steeped in Wartime history and
some substance Promises of attack drones
and more missiles but president
zielinski is warning allies without more
support his military's long-awaited
counter-offensive could be delayed we're
only in need some some more time not too
much and there was yet another plea for
Ukraine to be sent Western warplanes
today we spoke about the Jets very
important topic for us because we can't
control the sky we want to create these
uh Jets Coalition and I'm very positive
with it we spoke about it and I see that
in the closest time you will hear some
well the two leaders were meeting in
Moscow the Kremlin angry condemned the
military package Britain's announced its
giving
eventually
with itself
comments that were dismissed by the
Prime Minister I think it's important
for the Kremlin to also know that we're
not going away
right we are here for the long term we
remain steadfast in wanting to defend
Ukraine not just now to reclaim its
rightful territory but also to ensure
that Ukraine has a mean to defend itself
into the future as well Ukraine is still
keeping the world guessing about its
long awaited counter-offensive and well
it will begin and the longer that weight
goes on the more doubts will grow about
its ability to wage it effectively
from the eidetic beauty of the English
Countryside president zielinski flies
back to a war-torn country the promises
of Europe's leaders ringing in his ears
promises he's heard before but is still
no closer to Victory Dominic wagorn Sky
News at checkers